oh tell me how you watched it where you
were and how you felt good morning
so i wasn't in tokyo which was a shame
so we had a
watch party at home in the garden and i
had three of tom's other siblings and
lots of family and friends and other
swimmers and neighbors and we did a big
projection in the garden and we
um we filmed ourselves doing it and
we all raised a drink to tom and
actually it was really really lovely it
was a really joyous
moment and we um when you look at the
video we
we look like there's about 70 of us and
we look like
mad whirling dervishes just jumping up
and down and
um it was very very lovely we're looking
at those pictures actually jackie as
we're speaking to you
um oh no
[Laughter]
with your t-shirts on all cheering i've
just spoken to tom
oh no i've just spoken to him
and and i sent him the video from
twitter and he was like
mom i couldn't stop watching it i just
looked at one person and then watched it
again
and looked at another and saw another
and he was so
thrilled talk to me about how he felt
about the race
you know he he he always goes very quiet
before a race and i think that's really
good so he just goes into himself and
thinks about his racing so
we tend to keep the chat down but i knew
he was feeling confident you know he
knew he'd put in the work
he knew it was going to be a really
really tight race duncan scott is an
amazing swimmer
there was the russian the romanian
and he knew as he said it was going to
be a dog fight
but i've just said to him now did you
think he could win it and he said yes i
did
and won it he did by a fingernail so
he's just he feels like he's in a dream
at the moment you know his first
olympics he's only young and he's just
got gold
and he's not he wasn't necessarily
favorite going into the race was he
no he qualified fourth fastest into the
finals behind
duncan um the korean guy who'd had an
amazing semi-final
and maliuty and the the russians so
there was absolutely no way he was down
you know pip for favor but
i know tom you know he's got a brilliant
approach to his races
he knows how to move it on from the heat
to the semis to the finals
and he did just that and you know his
life has changed forever now
yeah um did he say that when he was i
mean did he have a lot of joy in his
voice when he was talking to you or was
it being quite methodical
before the race he was very quiet
contained and internal and very
methodical he knew what he had to do he
just wanted to get on
on with it after the race he said mom i
just feel like i'm in a dream
um i knew i could win it but none of it
sunk in
and of course he had to go straight off
that after that race for doping and then
for soft
tissue massage and then straight into a
training session because they have the
four by
200 free style relays tomorrow which is
really important race for great britain
so i don't think he's had time for it to
you know coalesce
um and settle with him yet and um but it
will
i'm sure uh let's a big shout out for
team mom i'm guessing that you did the
hard yards with him when he was little
i did i did you know as i said tom's one
of five and they were all swimmers
and so that's a lot of early mornings
and a lot of after schools and an awful
lot of weekends
racing all over the country and it's a
slog it's a real slog but
you know they put in the work all i do
is provide the support
and you know tom's just always been one
of those boys
you know from when he was a baby he was
just so positive he always thought that
life was for the taking and if he wanted
to do something he could
you know he wanted to learn to play the
trumpet he would if he wanted to be a
good swimmer he would
and so that positive attitude has just
taken him all the way to the top and
you know good on him it's been a joy
it's been a joy to be alongside him for
that journey
and can you put in words finally jackie
just how proud you are right now
i've just said to him tom my heart is
bursting
you know and it's not just because
you've you know you've won a gold medal
it's just the way he conducts himself
the way he picks himself up after
disappointments you know
he's had two bouts of covid this year
it's really knocked his plan off
you know i'm just so proud of the way he
just approaches it
and so professionally and with such
dignity
and you know and he always cares about
the other swimmers so that's what makes
me proud
uh little known fact mum is that 75
percent of gold medals so far have been
won by somebody called tom
we need to christen more babies tom
don't there you go and then
yes team gp of the future it's good to
talk to you jackie thank you so
congratulations great great thank you so
much thank you
thank you